this time she was keep you want to be
really crappy camera no strikes and
again problematize you're going fast
right and do whatever can I do any
problem ties going fast and you know be
predicting make sure you come up
[Music]
on the you Kennedy you got quite
understanding it he was trying a lot of
things look like it do you get what I'm
saying
but he's he was trying a lot of
accountants so I'm not seeing that from
the who kiss you should fill in
everything so I don't want you to
overpowering him let's see
you can see how I'm just using you and
your energy okay
[Music]
she did that site control or mouth
okay so liven up you can mean okay if
they're getting stuck let them out like
I let him out of back now
[Music]
so what how did I enter there
so she stopped not harming that so she
she straightened her arm on me so I take
the small joint
I can't move me young movie
she strained her arm again take the
smaller is moved again here's the arm
setup staying here
boom slowly right
click the catch on
again
with
okay so we have like oh he got me pinned
and I can't I can't 10.com and I can't
enter or there's no energy what he's
doing
somehow you feel like I can't I can't
transfer or I can't blend with it okay
that's the question
so let's look at blend let's look at the
concept of musubi blending you and and
its opposite non blending okay so we
remain is that at least two or more
elements or aspects of the entire
movement are in antagonistic
relationship when I don't have them
soupy and when I have musubi all of the
relevant aspects are in harmony with
each other producing a single and
desired for okay so if like if he
catches me here do you see again it's
it's not the elements that make my CV
it's my capacity to stop all antagonism
said see how do you see how I find that
one so you're you're not pinned you're
not pinned because he got your arm here
your pin because you you went back
you're not pinned because you stayed
still right you pinned because you tried
to move do you understand that so then
then this is exact
comes down sometimes the the one about I
don't have any energy to transfer well
his matter his mass and the and
gravity's pull on him and friction
working on him
those are all energy said that you can
use so you can pick DC so if he if he
what watches a Bangla translation alarm
okay now if you moved with that see you
don't have it so he's not giving me
anything he'll give me that do you see
and then I can get down but if he moves
with me then Europe you see go I'm gonna
try to do just push down some of the
other things let's say for the people
who dislike a couple reps with she does
she just she she I've gone here right
and she loosens up here so that her
shoulder doesn't get checked out well
that's when you come in here you see so
if he if he's here get your good grip
and I give him this angle I can't I
can't cut use this or you see that so if
I go to strike you just push the arm at
the cross Salado GC so but when he when
he loosens up the arm then I can use I
can come in and you'll feel that so it
feels loose right is loose you see and
you can come in we do it again juice
right it looks like we're just doing the
strike it looks like I'm doing this but
it's not right now I'm trying to do that
with boom
[Music]
the other thing like I said is if you
look at what I did it's that I didn't
harmonize the aspect just not that the
aspects aren't harmonious as I did
something that's not in harmony with
what's happening
I did something that's gonna include I
didn't do something but I think at slow
pace level it really is you did
something okay so some of the things
that I've seen is you're coming around
here and the guy starts coming around
see and then I see you staying here and
you trying to get the arm so we do it
again and I gave this example with the
schita right he's coming around and look
like a movie role right he always movie
I don't let him push up go no you push
this without tank on again you push it
is a fun game so my stain still while
the player is moving is that antagonist
stick to what's happening I kept saying
right obviously I always take too many
turns too many turns but I'm trying to
make the point and she keeps trying to I
turn I turn and I don't end up